today we're going to start with two
different interviews it's a tale of two
interviews with liar Congressman elect
George Santos a republican in the first
interview we are going to see George
Santos interviewed by a woman named Skye
ostricher from the political
personalities with Sky program this
seems to be almost like a friend of his
in fact it seems maybe they do know each
other from watching the interview
friendliest interview in the world and
yet it still is a disaster based on the
continued lies that Santos tells later
we will look at now Fox News
correspondent or contributor Tulsi
gabbard interviewing George Santos and
you know what the tools his credit she
does a good job of calling out his lies
so let's jump right into it as a
reminder for context this is George
Santos who won a seat at the U.S House
of Representatives as a republican he
basically made up his entire life's
history he lied about his work history
he lied about his educational history he
lied about being Jewish
um he said he's gay and it does appear
that that's actually that part is
actually true uh but he's in some cases
calling these merely embellishments in
other cases saying well I never really
committed a crime
uh and in other cases uh sort of
doubling down in fact on some of the
lies so this that you're going to see
this is an insult to journalism this is
one of the most absurd parodies of
Journalism that I've ever seen Sky
awestriker first question what made you
feel like you needed to lie about your
resume gets interesting quick what
caused you to even feel the need to
exaggerate who you are we'll start it
this way look
um I didn't outright lie
um about my work he did experience uh
actually I'm fairly well-rounded in the
financial markets and capital markets
I've been doing now whether you're
well-rounded or not you literally said
you worked at places you didn't work for
a very long time
um but I'll take you back to the
beginning So and I've worked as a
customer service agent for six seven
months of my life or so eight maybe if
in some at some point in 2011 2012 okay
uh and you know I'm not ashamed of it
Skye but the moment I put that on a
resume and I put it out there elitists
like the New York Times like to call
Blue Collar jobs like that odd jobs guys
you see what's going on here it's
because of the elitist woke New York
Times that wouldn't have taken his
customer service experience seriously
that he essentially had no choice but to
claim to work for Goldman Sachs or
wherever it was it's because of the woke
New York Times that he had to do it he
didn't really have a choice they forced
him into it because you know it just
doesn't fit their uh bourgeoisie style
lifestyle right so that bougie left
Media made me have to lie about my
experience it's it's those expectations
and those negative connotations from
elitist organizations such as the New
York Times that lead people like me who
I've I'm very comfortable in saying I
come from poverty I I come from a family
of absolute nothing and I've worked
really hard to get where I am today
um and the reality is is yes I I omitted
like past employment history that was
irrelevant to the role although one can
argue customer service is pretty
important but he also made up employment
history that didn't exist because of
Congress but I guess they just don't see
it that way
um and and you know for for poor use of
words maybe and yeah this guy made it up
whole cloth okay and he's essentially
saying they made me do it they're they
just have these X expectations it's
everybody else's fault that I uh that I
had to make it up which I kind of didn't
then he explains why he was married to a
woman now this I actually don't find
this to really be a super interesting
part of the story because
because of social pressures and stigma
and a lot of different reasons it's not
that rare that gay men at some point
have relationships with women or might
even be married to women it's it is
interesting to hear them explain it
though now the one thing I will say is
I'm sorry for having had a life for
having had a complicated life oh maybe I
married yeah I did marry young and I
married a young woman at the time and we
we pretty much were in love and then we
weren't because that's why I decided
after a long time like many who don't to
come out and say I'm gay and I'm not
going to lead you along and this is
toxic and this relationship isn't going
to work and I set myself free and I set
her free I think this is completely fine
I don't think this is a big deal
whatsoever then they go into what about
your constituents what are your
constituents thinking about all of this
dishonesty so George how do you think
your constituents are feeling right now
um I I can't answer that because I don't
know
um I have people who have reached out to
me and given me the utmost support I
have people who have reached out to me
frustrated with the reports and wanting
to know more and I have been giving the
same explanation to people one off for
the last couple of days I was silent to
the media because I don't dance to the
tune of the New York Times right
whichever MSNBC or whoever I dance to
the tunes of my constituents so I've
been very heavily intensively on the
phone talking to them calling them
making sure people he's been have by the
way this guy just makes up words heavily
incentively yesterday he made up the
word in grandiate and the phrase uh the
the knit and gritty as opposed to the
nitty-gritty he's constantly making up
words it's sort of like an interesting
aside who volunteered and it's been an
overwhelming response of George we
elected you to get a job done we didn't
care what your resume looked like quite
frankly right if they didn't care then
why did Eli of course is the question
well because the New York Times made him
one question has been will he resign
increasing pressure on him to resign
this interview was from uh two days ago
at this point point he makes it very
clear he's not going to resign however
maybe he will because things have
changed since get stuff done I will be
an effective member of Congress I will
be a diligent member of Congress and I
will be able to deliver results for
congress for the people of New York star
District because
I'm not going to allow this to deter me
from doing that right so making it clear
he's not going to resign however the
pressure continues mounting and maybe he
will end up resigning now here was an
interesting question and I'll you'll
find out why it's interesting very
quickly he has made claims about
property ownership in this interview
he's asked by Sky ostricher playing the
role of a of an interviewer in this
video about the property stuff take a
listen to what he says
okay I mean that's a good attitude to
have I have a few other questions that
maybe we can address really quick about
property that you own George do you own
property do you not
so George Santos uh me personally I've
never claimed to own property myself I
have never claimed to own property
myself okay that's pretty clear no I do
not own property I've I've never
purchased property under my name I've
got your family property I think my
family has property and I'm able to use
of their property and I helped them out
with uh you know keeping the books and
stuff like that but that's a family
affair okay so no property doesn't have
property never claim to own property
here he is saying he sold the property
uh okay let's see if I've got this lined
up right let's take a listen
you know it's funny I two years ago I
sold a property I had on 28th Avenue I
sold a property I had not I helped my
family sell a property of theirs I sold
a property I had like that's how you
know it's funny I two years ago I sold a
property I had on 28th Avenue all the
way down by the water right just go
straight right and it's because the
shelter went up on 20th Avenue and and
it was very controversial and and I sold
the property there but what I can tell
you is that that area should have never
been built on that is a swamp that used
to be the flushing airport and the swamp
took over it and then they insisted in
building up a an academy there you know
it's a beautiful building I think it's a
gorgeous project yeah I've never claimed
to own a property oh I sold a property I
had because I didn't like the fact that
a shelter went up doesn't really sound
like you're saying it's a family
property does it so just it's lie on top
of lie on top of lie then we get to the
issue of um his false claims that he's
Jewish uh Okay let's listen to that okay
and the controversy about your ancestors
in the Holocaust how did that how did
that become such a story in these
different Jewish Publications whether
they were in the Holocaust or they
weren't in the Holocaust and do I wish
you a happy Hanukkah or a Merry
Christmas
so as I've said many times and I think
you've heard me say this I always joke
I'm Catholic but I'm also Jewish
guys can't you tell he's Jewish
uh and I've made that joke because
growing up I grew up fully aware that my
grandparents were Jewish came from from
a Jewish family and they were refugees
to Brazil and that was always the story
I grew up with and I've always known it
very well and I've told it the way it
was told to me now if if It just strikes
me so odd that people are rushing to dis
inherit me from being Jewish or for even
allowing to he's there's no evidence
that those stories are true care for
Israel and Judaism in a time and and
guys he likes Israel why can't we just
call him Jewish I mean if it after after
all that why can't we just allow him to
do it now of course Rolling Stone report
George Santos who said he never claimed
to be Jewish once called himself a quote
proud American Jew
proud American Jew I never claimed to be
Jewish no I never claimed that
um okay and then one more video here
what does uh George say to people who
now worry they won't be able to trust
him but are there people I'm sure there
are what do you say to them that are
gonna hold this against you and say that
they can't trust you because of these
exaggerations that you've made
exaggerations you were able to trust
um
worse people they were able to trust
Andrew Cuomo who essentially harassed
women through his argument is they've
trusted worse people than me
they were able to trust his James who
harbored a sexual predator as her Chief
of Staff right they were able to trust a
Litany of politicians in this country
who have literally sold this country out
look at the president of the United
States so guess what I will make them
Trust Me by delivering results I'm not
here for self-empowerment self and
Grandeur I'm just here to get stuff done
because I want to leave a country better
off to the next yeah so I I guess you
should trust him because worse people
have held office a humiliating attempt
and an interview by Sky ostricher and
just lies upon lies the dishonesty is
just seeping through this guy's every
poor and orifice of his body
um horrifying a horrible liar and
fortunately Tulsi gabbard actually took
him to task